[Music]
and i killed sparky too
[Laughter]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy with double
vision
and this video we're breaking down
episode 8 of one division
the christmas carol esque entry takes a
trip through time
as you unveil a villainous vixen's
vicious plan and discover there's
a lot more going on with vision
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down
discussing our theories and how this
show could be tying into spider-man no
way home
time codes will be linked below if you
want to skip ahead but i first want to
talk about the dark hold
magic and that big reveal now as for the
darkhold this mysterious book was shown
at the end of the last episode
and i believe that it was part of the
ancient one's collection which we saw in
doctor strange
there was one missing from the shelves
and they were surrounded by hexagons
which is of course an aesthetic of how
the world is built
the orange glowing energy is typically a
sign of wizards
and from the different pigments used
throughout the show it does seem like
the colours represent the origins for
the spells
orange is your more typical magic
whereas wonders is red because she pulls
from chaos energy
agatha's however is purple and as we
learned in doctor strange
this is a color that is typically
associated with the dark dimension
it also explains her long life and we
have a full breakdown on this in case
you want to discuss
in more detail now as for the darkhold
this has been used to house several evil
spells that can manipulate the fabric of
reality
often referred to as the book of the
damned it was crafted by an evil elder
god
known as chithon who encased his most
devilish dealings inside of it
on indestructible parchment i'm always
worried that i pronounced chithon
wrongly so let me know if i have now i
think going forward
this will be a big part of the marvel
universe and in the comics it was
actually used to create the first
vampire
inadvertently this led to blade being
born and i can see it being tied to his
upcoming movie in some form or another
now episode 8 comes with a big reveal
and that is that the vision we see in
the hex is actually a fake one
and that wonder never took the real one
from the sword facility
it's something that we started
predicting back in episode 5
and i'm glad that for all the theories
we've gotten wrong
that this one and agnes being agatha at
least turned out to be true
my nerd cod still hasn't been revoked
thank god now against the character's
will
hayward decided to transform the corpse
into a weapon
and he was able to do this because as a
synthesized
vision doesn't carry the same rights as
a real person haywood was clearly
suffering a lot of anxiety over the snap
and the devastation that was caused by
it and thus
he like tony that his ptsd drive his
decision making
haywood wanted to put somewhat of a suit
of armor around the world
and therefore he turned to something
tall stark and handmade in order to do
it
i'm guessing that at the end of infinity
war caps sold vision's body on ebay
and that the stare that we saw was him
just weighing up whether he could list
it as like new or not
now going forward i'm predicting that
things end up similar to logan
where we have the two versions facing
off against one another
and this will lead to the hex version of
vision likely dying
as he tries to take the twisted one down
at the moment it hasn't been said that
betany has been cast in doctor strange
too
and this it makes sense that he's not
amongst the roster if he doesn't make it
out of this
i think marvel have to kind of play the
disney plus and movie things
in the mind state that not everyone
especially not my grandma who loves the
mcu but doesn't have the internet
will have seen the shows thus they kind
of have to play it where you could
potentially watch
endgame see wonder depressed at the end
of it and then going to doctor strange
where they're still being depressed
the fate of her kids is still up in the
air but i do think that they'll survive
and that will then be explained in
doctor strange 2 as her manifesting them
similar to say something like house of m
and what's hilarious about this reveal
is that in the show
after the evan peters recast betany said
there was still an actor coming down the
line that he wanted to work with since
he was a boy
he described them as a genius and it's a
troll that's as good as tom holland
posting fake spider-man 3 titles
to trick every single one of us it was
bet any
all along you're some of a [ __ ] you got
me
so yeah cataract was likely a pun that
makes my double vision one look good
and it was right in front of us the
entire time
i'm so glad i got that theory out there
before today now as for the episode
itself
the marvel studio logo pops in as always
but it's wiped out by a purple flash
before the red itself changes to the
distinctive color
we cut to salem massachusetts and see
agatha being led into the woods by her
coven
this was the time of the salem witch
trials which started in february of the
year beforehand
and ended in may of 1693 however
this isn't part of the actual trials and
it's actually the witches who are
holding agatha to account
for using magic above her station on the
queen witch agatha's mother
we can also see the broach that agatha
has won throughout the show and it turns
out that this was actually a family
heirloom that she took
the scene initially resembles her death
in the comics in which he was put on a
pirate and set a light by the salem
seven
however here it differs slightly as
there's eight and they use their magic
to try and kill her but it backfires
with a dark energy and wipes them all
out
agatha clearly wants to be good and this
very much speaks to her arc in the
comics in which he has gone back and
forth between being nice and evil
for the majority of the stories she's
actually been someone who has helped
wonder
so we may get that character development
coming down the line
just don't do anything more to her kids
here now i get this seems like she may
have been saved by someone or something
due to the fact that this power only
manifests at this point
though i don't want to get into the
whole mephisto thing again i can i can
see you rolling your eyes
witches were thought to be the brides of
satan
ralph is of course her husband and the
name itself comes from the word wolf
which is often a form that the devil
himself takes akikeda appeared in agnes
house in the last episode
and also in this one in the comics the
first appearance of mephisto was in the
form of a fly
so potentially that could have been
teasing towards it though the green
was very similar to another character
now it is possible that the overarching
villain is nightmare who is someone else
i think they could easily give
mephisto's powers to
without causing any controversy this
would also set up the dream aesthetic of
the hex
and lead into doctor strange 2 which
he's the arise to be a villain for
or she it might be a woman we're not
sexist here yeah now a nightmare is of
course what the hex has turned into
as well and it is possible that we'll
get several overarching villains in the
disney plus shows
i don't want to keep going on about why
mephisto might not be in it because of
china
but there are other reasons outside of
it that disney might decide to omit him
i was saying in another video that they
could just put mephisto in it and change
the chinese subtitles to say nightmare
but not everyone yolo's as hard as i do
so we don't know
nightmare and dreams are mentioned when
wonder is trapped under the bed
and i can imagine a post-credits scene
in the finale that does give us a tease
towards this
now an interesting thing is that
agatha's mother manifests to sort of
crown when casting her magic
and it is possible that wonder will
create a red one at some point to get
her classic look
we jump back to wanda in agatha's
basement and she's unable to enter her
thoughts because of their differences
and powers and abilities
now i did point out earlier in the week
that there were devil heads on the
pillars in the basement
and this is likely the figure that she
is a witch worships there's also a ram's
head
which is a satanic symbol i'm gonna stop
myself before i go back down that path
now aggie that also brings up runes
and how only the person who sets them is
able to cast a spell inside of them
i actually think that this will be the
key to defeating her and that next time
they might be set up around the town in
order to take her down
it also means that there is a way to
confine her and it sets up a big
weakness for the characters across the
board when we come to deal with them in
the future
and we learned that pietro or rather
fietro was brought across
and given the role of her brother
because she was so crippled by her grief
that she wouldn't ask any questions
there are two ways that you can take
this
in that either he's just a nobody due to
the continent common by agatha
or he's somehow been pulled through the
multiverse i think due to his abilities
that it might be the latter
but it's looking like the reveal might
just be one big disappointment
i'm kind of bummed out at the moment if
he is just someone from the town
as that might mean no x-men and who
knows
he actually might be the person under
witness protection i did go through the
town scene towards the end and try and
fish him out
but he wasn't there so i still hold no
hope
now aguila brings at west view and all
of the complex magics that wonder is
dealing with in the realm
agatha is obsessed over this as the best
she can do is mind control
and transmutation on a small scale but
wonder is of course running this across
the entire town
she wants to know how she did it and hey
i feel the same
just give us the answers now unable to
draw the truth out
agatha takes a dive into her mind and
can i just say i absolutely loved
catherine han in these scenes
as she's phenomenal at not only hamming
it up but also
adding the sinister side to the
character wanda has to go along with her
because she has her kids stashed away in
her bewitched basement
and this is actually a nod to how the
house that agatha lives in is the one
from bewitched
agatha takes the character on a trip
throughout her life i think it's now
fully established that witches can do
this
in thor ragnarok loki said he can't seem
to the future
because he's not a witch and later in
endgame friga was able to tell that thor
was a different person
because she said she was raised by
witches and because you look like a
completely different person now
we can gather from this that witches
have the ability to see backwards and
forwards
and who knows it may even become a part
of wonder's skill set at some point
here she sees her childhood with pietro
and i don't know if it's just me
but i think this might have been a
tangled reference now moving on
there's also a red tv that has been used
throughout the promotional material
we are introduced to wanda and pietro's
parents which debunks the idea that they
were the pair in the commercials
her dad sells dvd box sets of sitcoms
most of which have appeared as
aesthetics through the show
there's malcolm in the middle bewitched
i love lucy the addams family
who's the boss and i dream of genie the
family used to hold tv night and
this is also how the children learn to
speak english
wanda also used these as a way to escape
from reality
and this is why they were brought across
to the aesthetic of the show
as she was literally escaping from
reality vietro said she was suppressing
a lot of trauma
and it's an awesome scene watching this
play out she picks her favorite
the dick van dyke show which was the
first sitcom that the series centered
upon
it says on google at the episode title
of season 2 episode 21
is my husband is a czech grabber but we
see in the entry that it's called it may
look like a walnut
you better not be lying to me marvel you
know i like these easter eggs
now the aesthetic is absolutely spot-on
including the bedroom and kitchen scenes
which have of course appeared throughout
the season
the pieces interrupted though when the
explosion goes off that we know from
wonders past
killed both her parents amongst the
rubble she and her brother wait
his stark weaponry is dropped in the
location and when one doesn't go off
they spend two days
looking at the logo the red flashing
light on it of course appeared in the
first commercial
and it's clear that this trauma has
vastly shaped her life
wonder is pulled out by agatha and we
discovered that as a child
she used a probability hex now in the
comics one
actually uses hex magic and she has
based powers around probability
which are well tipper is simply look
because
wonder is able to alter the probability
of events she can swing them in her
favor
and this is how she stopped the bomb
from going off in the comics wonder was
actually given these powers as a child
by chitton
but whether that carries a cross we
don't know yet however agatha doesn't
discover what allowed her magic to grow
beyond this
and thus they enter the hydra labs which
is where she was experimented on along
with her brother
here we see loki's scepter which of
course housed the mind stone
now we did theorize that this scene was
actually wonder creating the mind stone
for vision's head
but we got it wrong like everyone who
canceled disney plus
and is missing out on this what do you
mean you just pirate it
anyway wonder actually removes the
housing unit from the scepter itself
and sees the traditional scarlet witch
coming towards her
this is likely wonder seeing the future
like witches can
and at the end of the episode she gets
her made-up name and this is very much
foreshadowing that
now coming into contact with the
infinity stones somewhat enhanced her
abilities
and it does explain how she became
vastly more powerful
wanda steps back into the room she was
held during the events of civil war
and we also see how the sitcoms are tied
to her life as she watched them
more than i've watched the mcu vision
walks through the wall
as we know he doesn't really have a
thing for doors and the pair sit on the
bed and watch malcolm in the middle
vision doesn't get the slap stick behind
it because
he's unable to understand certain
subtleties however he does
genuinely want to bring her comfort
after the death of her brother
wander clearly doesn't want to talk
about it much in the same way that she
shut down other conversations
that have almost uncovered the truth
vision actually gives her a look at true
humanity
and the highs and lows of it i think
this trip
really makes her appreciate the truth
and how griefers often
just love persevering agatha takes the
pair away
and tries to crack her and from here we
journey to the sword facility
we can see a news report about families
being reunited and similar to monica the
pair were robbed
of being with their loved ones when they
were returned i actually think that
maria will manifest in some form or
another to tempt moniker in the hex
as we now learn a lot about how the
entire thing operates
wonder just wants closure and debary
vision but she's been robbed of this
now due to the way that the vision is
viewed he's had a vastly different death
in comparison to tony stark
throughout far from home we watched as
peter parker encountered several
tributes to him
playing pretty much 24 7. both gave
their lives
but only one is seen as a death that
people should mourn and this has clearly
tormented wonder
there's no memorials for him because it
seemed almost like changing your iphone
but wonder deeply loved the character
and this is obviously making her grief
even worse
as she has no one that understands her
plight now because vision
isn't seen as a person it also means
that his will is ignored
and therefore hayward can experiment on
him wanda is almost buzzed through
initially
but she just blasts her way through the
doors and this juxtaposes monika's entry
as she had to wait to be given clearance
by hayward wonder goes to him
and he introduces himself as director
instead of acting director likely
changing it for monika
because he doesn't want her to see him
as a threat he allows her to see the
body
and it's almost like a reverse
frankenstein's monster scene
where he's being torn apart hayward just
sees him as a weapon
and saying terms like we're bringing him
back online instead of
trying to bring him back to life it just
shows his mentality
hayward says he isn't yours and she
flies down and tries to reactivate him
but she says she can't feel him this of
course is a phrase that the pair used
with one another to exemplify their love
and it missing here shows how much
wonder has lost
i'm not quite awkward now due to this
instead of taking the body
she leaves it as we predicted i did get
a lot of people asking
why i thought that warner didn't take it
when i came up with that theory
and the simple answer is because we
never saw her leave with the body
often in screenwriting if you don't see
something you shouldn't take it as a
given
and though hayward did seem like he was
trying to take vision back
i think the audience assumed a lot when
it came down to it if you cast your mind
back to episode 4 you will remember that
hayward actually sent moniker out on a
missing person's mission
and it was only by accident that wonder
was discovered hayward had absolutely no
plans about tracking him down before
this
and thus i think that he wasn't looking
for vision because he still had him
going forward you might remember that
from the start of far from home
there's actually a bit in memoriam to
him and this movie is actually set after
the events of one division
so it looks like things changed in terms
of how he was perceived
and it's like that he was getting in
memoriam because he dies at the end of
the show
spoiler alert now in her scarlet car
wonder finds the deeds to a house in
west view and she drives out there
though it does seem like agatha placed
this there we don't know for definite if
it was her
and i'm not sure exactly how she would
have known that wonder could have done
all this
this opens up the possibility for more
people behind the show
and let me know below if you have any
other theories now along the way i'm
probably talking about again
now along the way she sees herb and some
of the notable characters that i call
the trap squad
i think the mailman being a delivery guy
here
does highlight that he isn't mephisto
and it looks like the real mephisto
was the friends we made along the way
now the town is far from its pristine
self
and she very much views it as a place
that she can potentially improve
the snap obviously devastated the
landscape of the world
and it doesn't seem like they've managed
to fully get back on their feet
now the deed shows a place to grow old
in and it also has
words on it like to having to hold this
grant was given by someone called kate
weddle which is actually one letter
short of my wife's real name
and i've been telling you for months now
yeah it's all connected
now in the despair she builds the hex
without the help of agatha
and forms the house around her in the
destroyed lot one day is almost
completely godlike in the creation of
this reality
and shout outs to jake wood for pointing
out that like god
after creating the world she rested on
the seventh
seventh seventh episode wonder then
creates vision
and we see the scene from the trailer in
which he welcomed her
which we predicted would be the
formation of the hex happening in this
entry
vision says welcome home and the pair
sit down on the sofa
whilst he triggers the tv in a moment
that's similar to the ending of the
first episode
cut to the set lights and we go behind
the scenes to see agatha clapping
realizing that wonder really is a myth
capable of spontaneous creation
a nexus being that can control reality
from its chaos magic
she holds the children hostage and then
we cut to credits
i think going ahead that it will be
revealed that fietro was actually not
working for agatha
and that he was simply snooping around
too and that monika
vision and he will help the witch to
take down agatha
i'm still a bit torn on whether it's
really quick silver or not
and i kind of hope it is but it's also
seeming less and less likely
now jump to the mid credits scene and we
see hayward activating his secret weapon
the white vision by drawing from one
disabilities on the drone
they've managed to power up the corpse
and it's chilling seeing him activated
and i absolutely love this end credits
scene now white vision is actually a
version of the character that has
appeared in the comics throughout the
decade
after his death in infinity war it was
thought that he might take this form
and in a way i guess that he did well he
did because the hex one is the hex one
and the infinity war is the
never mind it's getting confusing now in
the source material white vision is the
character completely removed with his
personality
and opposite to the man that wonder fell
in love with in the source material it
was a while before things went back to
normal
but it's still awesome seeing this pan
out here
anyway i love how this ties back to the
comics and as mentioned at the start of
the video i think it will lead to a
face-off that means the hex vision will
have to destroy himself
in order to wipe out the other one this
will finally rid the world of this
dangerous weapon
and it could potentially give one of the
closures she needs
though i can imagine it being completely
devastating
i think the next episode will start with
them defeating agatha before moving on
to this
and as the magic gets worse then doctor
strange will be called in
now before we get into the news on loki
spider-man 3
and our general thoughts on the show i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss the finale
also huge thank you for getting my
videos trending six weeks in a row now
i'm not really expecting it with this
one but i just want to say thank you so
much for making me feel a bit important
i guess now this was another
spellbinding episode
and i think that this show is slowly
starting to deliver a lot of satisfying
answers
in the case of westworld season 3 many
of us had thoughts and theories on where
things were going
and this led to certain expectations
being made i think wes will let us down
whereas the reveals in this season even
if they did deviate from what was
expected
still worked really well i've had so
much fun guessing things over the past
seven weeks
and to see some of them come true whilst
others don't
means that i get the ego boost from
getting stuff right whilst
also the surprise of seeing where things
go it's the perfect balance for me and
i'm sure that many
of you feel the same especially if
you're someone who spends most of their
time throughout the week
obsessing over things like the yo gabba
gabba bit it just feels like this entire
show has been
similar to a comic book story arc and
that we get different issues every
single week
and all builds towards this big
overarching story
overall this was another great episode
and i can't wait to see what's around
the corner for the finale
now one division is sadly coming to an
end soon and there will be a friday of
blank
endless emptiness before we get falcon
in the winter soldier
releasing the following week it's also
just been announced that after the show
finishes we will get star wars the bad
batch
in may and once that airs we'll get loki
on june the 11th
i believe that's gonna be a nine episode
run two so plenty of stuff to look
forward to
and if what if is still holding its spot
in august we have so many things coming
down the line
now an interesting aspect is that one
division will be tying
in directly with spider-man no way home
this was confirmed long ago by the
mastermind behind it all
but the title reveal also brought a lot
with it in the announcement we watched
tom holland
zendaya and jacob battle on discussing
it before we got its full name
there were a couple of cool details in
the lead-up to this including the
t-shirt that had the equation on it that
peter parker worked out in homecoming
on the board itself there were also
several hexagons and the logo itself
glitched in a similar tv effect that
we've seen throughout one division
we also know that several characters
from the multiverse are coming across
such as alfred molina and of course
jamie foxx now jay jonah jameson
is already here and it may be revealed
that judah far from home
happening after one division that this
is how he joined the universe
tin foil hat mode on that one but just
just something i'm thinking
now hexagons have of course been set up
in one division and the hex itself
as it's linking in i'm guessing that one
division might see the multiverse really
open up
though it kind of already has through
the use of quicksilver
now there's also tesseracts on the board
too and as we know from the mcu
this can be used to travel from one
place to another potentially a
tesseract could also be used to go from
one place to another not only across
time and space
but also the multiverse itself it's also
worth pointing out that cubes in general
can be made from hexagons
and therefore we have this idea of a
tesseract basically being a
three-dimensional hexagon
there's also a benzene symbol on there
and uncle ben
has been dead for a long time i'm sorry
that was so bad either way there's a lot
going on here
i love the little comments on stuff like
stay home and home worlds
which is what i thought the movie would
be but i guess that's too boring
and i must be a boring person because
i'm still chuckling to myself a bit
over that terrible uncle ben joke now no
way home also makes me think that the
movie
might end up with him crossing over into
the sony verse and ending up there
whilst he helps out venom immobius
i don't know exactly what's happening
though which is why i want to hear your
thoughts and theories
and of course everything you think is
going to be happening in the next
episode
we have so much to unpack and i'm
guessing there's going to be a ton of
more things dropping before the finale
next friday
i just wanted to be here but until then
i'll read what you have to say
so so make sure you leave a good comment
what do you mean heavy spoilers as an
idea that's not that's how i meant
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
store on the 28th of february
in which you're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase three 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the theories
how the show connects to doctor strange
the one about vision
and the yoga bagaba commercial we've
gone over the entire thing and pointed
out some really cool details
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i mean poor and i'll see you next time
take care peace